thank you
all right for people who are joining
this live stream we are talking about
code assistance tools for wolfram
language
and looks like we're starting off with
noaa uh
showing package editor formatter
settings
cell so nowhere do you want to show your
screen
yeah i'll go ahead and chat okay
so uh you can see the window with the
two
um the screen for two windows right yep
yep
okay um yeah so basically um we've moved
the uh the capo formatter um
palette uh into a docked cell
um that's a toolbar you know underneath
the script and package editor toolbars
um and so basically you know everything
that was in that palette
um is now in these sorry could i just
um could somebody i see a message about
um
oh okay but um
okay no problem all right uh
okay go ahead i'm sorry now i'm paying
attention okay
course um so uh yeah i mean
so this was the function could you
repeat what you said i'm really sorry i
was
i was distracted by an asu
okay so i think in in um the last one of
these meetings um
you know we so you know the format cell
button was added
to the you know package and script
headed to bars
um and there was uh you know a separate
palette
um for uh you're setting the
indeed right okay so you're going to
integrate these so let's see the results
right yeah so so so yeah there you go um
this is literally just the the settings
that we had last time
um but in the doc cell here
nice work except i don't understand okay
so hold on
open something up and let's see airiness
to its thing uh
okay let's make this bigger
um so yeah i mean obviously you can
format the cell
and then you can use the airiness make
it super airy uh
is it obvious to people that those
controls
aren't self operating and that they
still need the format in other words
that that there's a sort of an okay
button aspect
of that thing that's above that that
um uh ribbon so to speak
right so i think that was actually a bug
um this should be
it doesn't have continuous action but
when you let go of it yeah there we go
it should reform oh i see okay fine
and that's just the speed ups i can talk
about next that just takes a second yeah
okay all right fine okay let's talk
about the next okay i love that airiness
thing i think that's great i think
people will understand that well
it's really nice um okay indentation i
don't understand the the
alignment of the word indentation with
that button and things like that
yeah we went back and forth on this uh
in the group quite a bit
basically uh you know you you can change
so this is the indentation character
right
um and so it can either be a tab or it
can be a certain number of spaces
oh i didn't understand that at all okay
i didn't understand that at all i
couldn't read that i mean if it had a
colon after the word indentation it
would help me
oh i see okay so so it was unclear that
this is essentially like a heading
yes it was completely unclear i couldn't
i couldn't read that
okay okay so what i think i think if you
say arines
colon indentation colon that would help
this a lot
yeah and then i think i would understand
it i just couldn't read it
okay um and then
okay so then that one is
can you see can you hold the pull down
which says the four pull down
yeah so you have a discreet list of
options there as opposed to
just having tabs in a different and two
space four spaces six spaces eight
spaces
all as a pull down
why not do that i mean why not just say
airiness that and then indentation
and then it's a single pull down that
just says tabs and as you pull it down
it says tabs two spaces four spaces etc
sure okay and that way you might be able
to avoid the colon
ism yes yeah yeah
all the controls will be a bit more
consistent yeah okay
in an ideal world we would also change
uh or have the width of the tab be
configurable and i i think after 12 2
we probably should it's just a little
late to do some of this okay fine
but then that can be part of that pull
down
oh having an input field in the pull
down no
there's no input field we're not going
to have people with 13
spaces for their tabs it doesn't matter
well what configurable then
i mean what do you mean by well when you
render a tab how many spaces are you
rendering it as
what is the effective width of a tab
oh well we're talk okay okay sorry right
um okay
so it's just tabs showing us two you
know four spaces tabs shown as eight
spaces
and then it should just say eight
literal spaces
after that in the pull down yeah i mean
you know the front end i don't i believe
there might be
you know hidden options to control it's
not there yet
we don't need to talk about it yeah i i
i just said this
that that's something that we should do
post 12 too
no but i'm just saying i don't think
that i mean is this even related to
formatting though
yes well i i i don't understand your
question because it's exactly the sort
of thing you would be able to configure
in any other editor right but we should
put this in in the future we're not
ready for it yet
the design we've just described has
extensibility for that
noah do you agree is there any issue
with this no not at all um we just put a
delimiter
in the in the drop down and you'd have
your tab widths and you'd have your
literal spaces
absolutely yeah right okay what is the
re-parse button
a hedge a thing that is needed
so it takes okay i get it
okay it's a slight hackery thing and we
need it for right now
well i think we're always going to need
it okay
re-parse boxes before formatting that is
pretty incomprehensible
can you tell me in words of uh you know
what is that what is the i mean i can
decode what that means but what why
don't you tell me for a user why do they
care
because the boxes that they're currently
formatting and you know whatever
notebook or dotted you know uh package
that they have open
the boxes might not be the source
that they think it is and the boxes
themselves
might be wrong according to their
expectations
that you know that need re-parsed you
know it's possible you know you can
un-format
cells and type retype them and screw up
precedences of operators and things so
that
the boxes um visually you know
the code looks the same but now all the
precedence you know
the boxes are now on you know you know
they're they're not the same structure
as before
and i don't know where it happens
i don't know if it's even front end bugs
versus people
you know manually typing things in but
i've in my uh in the course of my
testing you know various dot m files and
notebooks and all sorts of things for
this
uh it happens a lot it's in
documentation notebooks
and weird things um where
okay okay okay okay okay gremlins are
coming
and changing the underlying expression
representation of boxes
and what you're saying here is you want
to re-parse these things so that they
are re-canonicalized
correct yeah yeah okay so the next point
is that the thing you've described
should be communicated to qa
because it's potentially bugs am i
making sense
potentially except we don't know where
the box is i
don't care i don't care please just
communicate what you just told me
communicate to qa let them create some
tests and see whether they can find
such you know box modification going on
fair
yep okay so with respect to this
i think that description is
incomprehensible
okay so
um i mean kind of my own view here has
been
if you know if it's really needed then
why not just always have it on
yeah i mean there's a speed hit is the
problem too
how significant well yeah i mean
i i don't have yeah i mean i don't have
to find the information
i mean i think i think that this is more
of a
um i mean i i would say if it's
typically 10
then we'll just eat it um yeah i agree
with you if it's typically 50
then we should talk
um it's not the bottleneck currently i
can say that for sure
then let's not have that option let's
have it by just
for this version let's just do it and
don't option it
yeah make sense
and and later on if if we um
i mean i think the option would be i
think it should be under advanced
and i don't know what other advanced
things we'll have but this will be
something which says
under advanced there'd be a sort of
additional opener thing it would say
something like
um do not um
uh i would say a checkbox for the case
that you don't usually do that is
something like um
um do not re-parse yeah
um underlying box expressions
you know you know something like do not
re-parse
and canonicalize underlying box
expressions
okay that would be my suggestion for
what it would say in the advanced thing
yep
and we can definitely there will
definitely be more advanced settings in
the future too
that would necessitate that menu anyway
fine then let's
plan on that noah makes sense to you
i like this this ribbon very much it's
good good stuff um
okay any more to see here uh so okay i
have
just a question or two um the slider is
um you know so it's active right once
you you drag it and let it go
it formats should these be as well
why not everything then okay i don't see
why not i think it should be consistent
yeah it's confusing if it's different
okay so in other words as soon as you
select it does its thing i don't know
what other action would cause it to do
its thing
otherwise there in other words if you
reset the space
count show it again in this case re set
it to spaces
i see okay and then set it to two for
example now oh you have to do that
incomprehensible i don't make people do
that okay
i would never guess that i guess that
cool okay that was that was all i wanted
okay
um so because we have this and noah has
you know done a really good job speeding
all this up and actually having this uh
deliverable
i'm wondering if the palette is
completely obviated now
um how do you even get to the palette
oh it's good okay i think the text
resources are broken yeah okay that's
fine i mean
it was just showing the same thing that
we have in the cell now i think the
palette is obsolete
well but um in regular notebooks
with input cells i see
so i don't know what people think
well what i would do there's
no way of of letting people get
a noah style ribbon in a regular
notebook
on request is there
what's the request something in the menu
john i guess that could be in the in the
window menu for example
enable just like we can say not for 12.2
okay but so the toolbar that menu
i mean i mean yes if we want to do this
we could figure out something but
it's we're i mean we're getting close to
closing the door on twelve twos
then what i would recommend
let me see the the the menu that you
have right now on the pallets thing
could yeah i think we're going to have
to because of timing
we're going to have to have this in um
as a stand-alone palette
yes i mean in 12-2 that's that's fine i
just mean
so even after 12-2 what people would be
no i think the answer is what we do
after 12-2
is before we have the full generic
toolbar
what we do is under the when you window
menu when you say toolbars
which right now that's obviously going
in in deep modernization
um the
um uh
you know that is going to be when noah
hopefully
delivers the generic notebook toolbar
all of these things which are selectable
toolbars here
will have some different mechanism right
yep
um okay
there's a question from ride on our live
stream are you able to enter a value for
the slider as you can for labeled
sliders
for the airiness i i don't think you
want that
i think airiness is too complicated a
concept and i just think
you know oh i like airiness 7.2 is not
going to be a thing
yet also these aren't um uniformly
distributed they appear to be uniformly
distributed but they're actually not
underneath
so okay value is somewhat not
unintuitive as you say
right i i think it's not i think it's
one of these things where it's like
you if you if you see it and you like it
be happy
but it's not a um a precision it's it's
too
too much stuff is bundled into that
number right now
um and you know i'm the i'm saying the
caveat now
and and the number might change in the
future i'm yeah well
you know in my okay all right so noah in
terms of that standalone code formatting
uh palette um if there's anything you
need to do to clean that up you should
do it
um but i think we should have it for
this version
okay and so can i just confirm if we're
having this palette are we also having
this or no which absolutely your
beautiful ribbon
absolutely okay right but the whole
point is the palette
is for the use case of dealing with a
a regular notebook no no i understand
yeah
i understand i just didn't know if you
wanted piracy between uh
this and this uh yeah no i think it's a
hack right now
okay i mean we've got you know the the
palette is the escape
valve for dealing with this
functionality in non-uh script
notebooks yeah okay non-packaged
notebooks
okay is there any implementation of what
you're showing here in the cloud
not that i'm aware of brenson okay
can we open communications with the
cloud team
to see what we can do for that i mean
they don't have a package editor story
yet
but they're building one
right okay so just tell john show
you know briefly on on this and let him
figure out what to do with it
make sense
okay right what's next
right so um in the last meeting also
i mean i can share content please show
yeah
sorry one second
um yep i have a terribly
messy desktop right now but um
so i wanted to talk so in the last
meeting we were talking about how slow
the code formatter was
yes um you know move especially
visible through you know moving the
airiness slider back and forth
have you solved the problem um like
there there were two big problems and i
solved the first one
um and i can talk about them if we care
but um i can also just one sentence
summary of what was slow
um i was doing work that the front end
had already done
so all right fine just
thing that is still slow what is it so
we need
i need to associate all the little boxes
with
their positions in the you know the
entire
the overarching box structure that came
from the front end
and doing that recursively is what i'm
doing
currently and that's slow and what i'm
reorganizing things to do
is to just have one single map indexed
call
for the entire tree structure once
you know for everything and then you
know and that will be
much much much faster so hold on hold on
hold on the issue is
you've got a a dom part
so to speak a piece of the notebook
yeah yeah it needs to know i mean
mapindexed is just going to give you its
part numbering
that's all i need that's what i'm using
though yep
um
uh
so i mean i'm just working through that
right the problem is that i need to i
can't do the entire tree naively because
you know there are these edge cases of
when something's not just a row box but
a graphics box or some other you know
more complicated box
i do not want to descend into those
because those are now you know they
might be you know hold
you know the boxes might have weird
attributes and all these things that i
don't want to descend into
and so if if it's only purely row boxes
then yes
this is the great thing to do the fast
easy thing to do so
and understand doesn't the front end
have all kinds of tagging for these
structures
john even though i'm trying to avoid
john being yeah um
so um the
you're talking about like the the
tagging we use for debugging
for example maybe um so the debugging
tags are not sufficient um
they're they're they're not kind of
universally enough placed
and they don't deal with the um
with uh the concrete syntax
which is sometimes what brenton needs to
deal with um
but it's i mean it's fine uh map indexed
that's exactly what i need though and
this is you know it's just needing um to
separate
out the the two cases and uh yeah just
reorganizing the code
so and and and and by the way this comes
back to
you know what we discussed uh oh a
couple meetings ago
in terms of being able to uh um
take the the part numbers that uh
brenton is generating
and map them back in you know
into the front end onto its boxes um
exactly
yep so yeah
yep yep okay
well okay so i'm not sure i have
anything to contribute to this
but it's just no yeah i'm in the middle
of it but i mean that's the plan
and it'll be much you know much speedier
and much more good
okay all right let's let's continue
what's next
uh well if we don't want to bother jaw
and i'm not sure
well but i want to know what's happening
with your whole code
assistance system i mean i haven't heard
about that for more than a month
so i mean the whole thing with with code
suggestions
all that kind of stuff where are we at
with that
so in terms of the the front end support
um i had hoped to get at least uh
you know the the thin edge of the wedge
of
you know something that would enable
some prototyping but
um that ended up not happening
you know as a result of uh you know of
the last minute push for 12
2 so um well so
just but brenton you must have a bunch
of things
that you've developed because i mean
there's tons of stuff we've talked about
right all of your
linting tools all of the stuff about
bracket matching and so on show us where
you're at with that
well are you asked where are you asking
me to show that in the front end
or in like sublime or vs code or
something
well any of the above but i i would like
to see it
i want to see progress and i want to
understand what you've got
like there's you know machine learning
stuff there's the rules stuff there's
you know what does the linter actually
do you had a test bed version of the
linter
right show us that even though it hasn't
been integrated yet how has that been
progressing
well we've talked about this before um i
mean so i've been adding more rules
but i don't know if you're interested in
just seeing more rules
well yes i'm interested in seeing the
usability of it for large blocks of code
right and we've got to understand how to
do that i've been suggesting
to you various rules to add yeah right
and
i mean can you show it i can show it in
something that's not the front end
yeah that well what do you mean i mean
you've got a test bedroom
something that's not integrated like
sublime
brenton brenton you don't need to tell
me that that i'm i'm i'm saying to you
what i'm interested in seeing is the
algorithmic part of
how you are making suggestions for code
right you can show that to me in
whatever tool you want but i thought you
had a pretty nice
test bed in the front end for doing that
well
there's not no there's nothing front-end
specific about any of this because
nothing
i don't care you can show it a note but
you can show it somewhere else if you
have to show it somewhere
else but but i want to correct your
intuition
about what exists well
what i care about is you've got a big
block of code
take a big block of code i can give you
some blocks of code i've just been
writing
and i want to see it give me suggestions
about that code
in the front end i don't care where i'm
seeing it i care about what the
suggestions are
not where i'm seeing the suggestions
made i suggest seeing them in the front
end because it's easier to
do that but if you have to show it to me
and some other editors so be it
well no so yeah i mean this is just
purely the algorithmic part of this
that is current this is divorced from
whatever presentation that i've been
i know i know that that's what i'm
asking about i'm asking about the
algorithmic side of it
like for example the bracket guesser
what is the state of the bracket guess
sir
um the same as several months ago i mean
i don't know why why why hasn't that
made progress
i think timothy's here yeah i'm here
so what's the story
so the story was that i've uh i've
retrained
uh i've returned the network uh to do it
and i'm currently in the in
and the results weren't uh weren't good
even though even though i did more code
and so on so
i'm hunting i'm handing the data
i thought previously that we had a
somewhat reasonable heuristic
for deciding whether okay we got two
different heuristics going around one is
the bracket ghosting heuristics
i don't know whether those whether
there's something further needed for
those john maybe you can say something
about that
oh sorry um the woest question again
no problem i told you not to pay
attention so you're doing the right
thing
um it's uh the question was um the
uh heuristics for ghosting for bracket
ghosting
of which is the close bracket type thing
right which where we had where we had
discussed right
well so you've um
um oh sorry you are talking about the
type being or you know the auto matching
when you're typing right
yes that's correct yes okay um
the uh it's not clear to me what
connection this
has to timothy stuff um
well here's the point here's what i'm
saying what we had discussed previously
is to provide for the machine learning
group to provide you
a trained network as a piece of c code
that you could insert
to be the thing that deals with the real
time you know bracket okay
okay i kind of remember that now um the
um
i i yeah i do remember you're discussing
this i will say that
um i don't have
a lot of faith in that approach i could
be wrong i will admit that i could be
wrong but i don't have a lot of faith in
that approach
there are two significant issues in my
mind
one is a predictability issue
i know yeah i know we all agree but
yeah i mean it but you know not just
whether or not it does a good job
but that it you know operates by some
rules that can be intuited
here's the thing here's the case that i
think it's going to be useful okay
you've got a big block of code you start
editing inside the code
right now that code turns red and purple
and green and i don't know what
right because it's it's complicated what
it's got to do
yeah right yeah i think what whatever
that does if there is a machine learning
heuristic
that can be used that prevents the
cascade of of of reddening so to speak
it will be a good thing you see what i'm
saying so it inserts a ghosted bracket
and then doesn't spread the reddening
right and knowing how to do that i don't
know exactly i don't know whether that
can be done with a rule-based
approach or whether that has to be a
machine learning heuristic i do not know
what i do know is that that is the goal
well i
i i believe that you know
there are a comparatively safe set of
rules
which can cover a number of cases right
then that will be enough
you you will you know once you see those
cases you will probably say can we do
more
and that's where we'll continue to go
back and forth but i
but i do think there's a baseline that
uh i agree with you
that a heuristic set of rules will
safely cover all right fine i mean
so we're not okay so what timothy is
reporting
is machine learning cannot magically
match brackets
it worked it worked uh quite good
on sneak pet code which are
typically notebook code the the
one-liners and things like that and
and for for more like package code
then it became uh
written yeah you're using the old
network
ah this is not going anywhere
it's broken
to to add code from the package and so
on
uh things were more messy and it wasn't
it wasn't actually working at the moment
yeah okay so i don't understand what
you're saying to me
you're saying totally right because i
didn't succeed in extending
large blobs of codes okay so you managed
to do it for small fragments but not for
large blocks of code
yeah is that right okay
so but brenton i mean the big thing that
we are
counting on you delivering you know
after 12
2 is this you know is
the kind of linting type tools you know
directly in the front end i'm not a
front-end developer
um i'm not sure i know brenton what
we're asking for from you
is what we have talked about for a year
and a half that's unreasonable
you need to talk on about front-end
features i'm not talking to you about
that i want to see
given a block of code i need to see what
you are
saying should be indicated on that block
of code
do you understand what i'm saying as a
symbolic representation of what is the
lint
annotation of that block of code i mean
this is what's
existed from day one of my stuff i i
know
i know so i'm saying i want to see how
this is progressing and how we're
getting towards actually deploying it
not
it's not progressing at all why not you
need to ask
john that that's not what i'm saying
what i'm saying to you is
make sure if you have a way of
generating a symbolic representation
of what it is annotated in the code
right
then there is a separate project which
involves
noah and john or john's team to
actually deploy it in the front end and
there is another project
to deploy this in sublime etc am i
correct or am i not correct
yeah i mean that's vaguely correct yeah
i mean i'm not sure what's being asked
right now
other you know i mean what more what
what else is needed
from my end progress
no i'm asking other people that is that
are blocked by
what i'm doing what what is needed on my
end
anything um
if i'm the one that's not making any
progress then i'm like
okay but so wait a second wait a second
okay can somebody explain devin are you
you're project managing this right yes
okay
so can you tell me what's going on yeah
well um
i i think the state of this project is
that bretton has all these
tools that you know can be used in
sublime and visual studio code
so brenton from a day-to-day basis
brenton is working on those tools is
that true or not
that's true yes okay so so you are
progressively adding rules
and all that kind of thing is that
correct brenton i mean yes and
and even more stuff sure yeah okay
but so what is the output okay so you've
got this output here
okay so then you have a deployment of
this output through
sublime for example and you also need a
deployment of this output
through the cloud and through the front
end is that correct
if you say it's correct it's correct
[Music]
what do you mean i mean i don't
understand i don't understand what are
you saying
i mean your project is about providing
code assistance tools to people writing
code
yes now people are going to write code
in notebooks and they're going to write
code
in text editors your project is about
supporting both of those cases am i
correct
um in as far as those are both
representations of code yeah
what yeah but i don't understand
you say you're saying you can't demo it
in the front end because the hookup to
the front end has not been done
correct right i know that i'm saying
you have you had six months ago you had
a pretty good test bed
of what it could look like in the front
end with squiggly red lines and all
kinds of things like that
incorrect whose was that code
i mean it was a graphical fake mock-up
if that's if all you care about
are the fake like no no no no i don't
care about that i care about this
project actually getting done
okay and apparently there's been a
disconnect here
because something went wrong so devin
can you explain
i'm sorry wiggly lines whatever you just
said
it was a pipe dream that has never
existed okay well then that's inadequate
then something went wrong
wrong with project management as far as
i'm concerned being shown things where
you know we had agreed a year and a half
ago that that was going to get
implemented
right devon what happened to it
the i mean the front end side is in my
queue
right so it's far down in your clue so
you're not going to get to it so you
have to delegate
no no no no no no no that's not true
that's not true okay we'll explain
um the uh um
so there were some
frankly comparatively minor things like
the implementation of the appropriate
squiggly lines
which um which i could have prior to
prioritize but i didn't bother because
they're not useful by themselves
um the big thing which uh
which i was very worried about was
you know this issue of how we map uh
brenton's syntax tree to the front end
syntax tree
and so this is the thing which we
discussed
i don't know how long ago it was six
eight weeks ago something like that
um and uh
you know at which point you know i
believe
that that problem um you know i believe
we have
now a pretty good plan for solving that
problem
um and then it's just
comes down to implementing that plan and
that's you know
as i said earlier i'd hope to have
something that
you know people could begin building
prototypes on top of
before 12 2 and it just didn't quite
make it
that isn't in our list of top priority
front-end projects
so it needs to be added well it's in my
list
well i understand but it is not in the
list that i'm you know
we know what our top priorities for
right now are
well we've had
the you know the discussions you're
talking about have
been in the context of a particular kind
of front-end project
and oh yeah fine so this is a different
one so this is a
okay so then what you're going to
deliver is something that can take
brenton's symbolic representation
and deploy it as something that one can
see in the front end is that correct
yeah i mean it basically enables brenton
to say
i i have this thing in my tree i want to
attach an annotation to
so now i want to get the front end
handle for that thing uh
and uh and from there on out you can
just do standard things like attach
cells and that kind of thing to uh
you know to be able to work with it uh
and and then as i said there are a few
smaller things that have been requested
which
you know were not fundamentally hard i
just hadn't prioritized them because if
i delivered them
they would be kind of useless by
themselves okay so brenton
your linting tools how scalable are they
can they work on large blocks of code
yes the answer to everything you're
asking about me is yes
yes yes i'm waiting for everything else
it is scalable
there's nothing i mean but but but
brenton
they're clearly a rules it's never been
really tested in the wild
with real users and so on and i suspect
that they're going to be
i mean we tons of developers use it
every day i don't know what you mean
in okay in what environment in workbench
or what
yeah well no there are other workbenches
a whole separate okay so can you show me
a demo
demo of of the what you're talking about
for sublime or anything else any other
text editor
yeah sure um so
i mean just opening up a random file
that has to have a wl
extension um no no i don't want to see
toy code i want to see a big block of
real code
then tell me what do you any piece of
code
just read in any piece of code any piece
of wl code
from anywhere i just a piece of code
that fills the screen
okay great no that yes okay that's fine
it's a little
a little bit okay great and tell me what
do you want to see if you don't want to
see this
no no that's fine it's just i'm looking
at this code it's just
i'm asking whether it's typical code
it's fine okay
so now show me what so this is running
through the language server protocol is
that right
yep okay so then what you're seeing here
i some of the stuff i mean so what are
the what are those um
uh uh triangly things well we've talked
about all this before and you yelled at
me for showing this and i'm hate
i'm hesitant to even start explaining
what ligatures are with these fonts that
i've done
do you actually want me to explain any
of this sure
so a big part of our operators
i mean it's the triangles are the
association operators
oh god yes okay
sorry i said oh okay and so the issue is
you don't have a font character you
you're putting those in
as an alternative to a font character
because this editor does not support
our fonts is that right it supports our
fonts i didn't feel like
importing them because as i want to
continue
what what is actually the the font
feature that i'm
actually wanting to use here are the the
double square brackets that just require
actually just saying open you know open
open
in the source code and then get treated
as a single ligature uh
in the font which is a unique feature of
the font stuff that i've worked on
um all of this other stuff is you know
pretty common in other
coding fonts but this is unique because
it is
um yeah i don't know if there's a i mean
anyway if i add other square brackets
you can see that they don't
you know they correctly ligaturize
ligate
they they correctly ligate so anyway
could okay just
just to show me if you if you say that
if you do an
open you know say just plus you know
whatever something like okay go
go ahead yeah no no no i just just just
just
show me you know a open open bracket
open bracket yep okay now show me one
with
with uh with the b ins okay now no a
a triple open a triple open bracket
well that's i mean okay no what does
this actually do is you type a
and then you type open bracket and you
type it again
okay now type it again now type
okay that's beautiful right great
wonderful
now why is association not working that
way
what do you mean well association is not
represented in our language with
triangles
it's represented with a different glyph
yeah that's a i could easily bring in
hours this is this is a tangent i didn't
feel like i don't feel like going down
like this is just the default glyph of a
font that i'm using
that's irrelevant for what i understand
but for actual users
that's very confusing the the choice of
this glyph is a decision that brenton
made he can make a different decision
okay but so you're proposing that we
change the language
so that association brackets are
triangles
absolutely okay so then why aren't we
using a glyph that looks like
association brackets we're not using
anything
i am like john just said i brenton has
made a choice
okay but what is the default if somebody
is using
your tools in sublime
what is the default choice that they get
yeah i know this was
a mistake even having this i didn't know
there
this is the okay but then so that so
then it doesn't ligate
so but it would be nice for users if it
did ligate
right why would why would users not want
to ligate it the only issue is
it's weird to ligate to something that
doesn't look like our usual font
characters
but it is good to ligate to something
that does look like our font character
well there's
there's there's also the issue of of
what actual
fonts can we assume are available
to fine which we and the font control
system is very different presumably for
sublime than it is
you know we have much less control there
is that a true statement
well it's not a it's not it's just that
it uses installed fonts there's no
i mean i understand but if you try and
ligate
to a a character that isn't available
what does it do
that's not an action ligating is not an
action the user does
look you just changed that configuration
file you had a configuration file right
that specified what to do what i'm
saying is
if if the best thing to have happen
would be for the default configuration
file
when editing.wl files not possible
no okay why is it not possible that's
changing the default font
of a text editor that we don't control
like i mean
okay just walk me through this walk me
through this you're you're i i i i
i i i think the company i i
i think brenton i'm not stupid come on i
understand what you're saying
right that's the default font of another
program
i don't understand i understand but you
can obviously okay so we have to think
about how we're going to provide this to
users
right so an example of what we can do is
we can say here is a configuration file
you could use
if you had this font installed yeah i
mean something but
the phrase default font we should stop
using
okay fine so in a default font we cannot
provide ligatures
that's basically what you're saying
because we don't have the characters to
ligate
to i understand that that seems
reasonable
now but we could do a trick where we
ligate to a character that is available
in other fonts which doesn't look like
the characters we normally use
i think that trick is a mistake although
if we want to tell people how to set
things so it does that fine
does that does that make sense yep
so is there a workflow right now that
talks about how i mean i don't even know
how you
how you set this up like how does it how
does it configure itself for the
language
server protocol and all that kind of
thing well this is
this the language server protocol is
completely unrelated to all this font
stuff
i i understand that i understand that
but i'm asking you if i
have a raw imp a raw deployment
of sublime and i open a wl file
how does it find the relevant uh tools
to be able to do the right syntax
coloring for our language i mean
i thought we had talked about all of
this before in the past um
so by default there's no understanding
of wolfram language
in other text editors so the very first
thing you do
oh well and so a completely uh fresh
install of sublime doesn't even have
lsp installed and so you
you even so is there a workflow that we
have documents so in other words it
requires users to do a certain amount of
messing around
is that correct yes okay fine is that
is that messing around documented in
some um uh
in some workflow documentation it's
becoming more documented
yes okay so with respect to
every one of these text editors will no
doubt have its own extension mechanism
and its own way of inc
you know invoking this stuff and so on
is there
you know i i don't know the ecosystems
of these text editors
the but the best thing would be i mean
for example
uh you know is it i i just i just don't
know what the ecosystem looks like
i mean whether there's a you know
package manager you know single
get function that you can run that will
just magically do everything
or whether you're necessarily having to
do five steps yourself
well yeah i mean and it depends on the
editor yeah some are easier than others
but i mean
i mean there's an adjusting of
expectations i feel is needed because
like we don't control
any of this we can okay we deal with a
lot of
situations like this elsewhere right
where we're trying to install our stuff
in an external environment right and
it's a mess
it's a jungle everyone is different
right but so
each one we have to you know lovingly
look at each one
yeah yeah and figure out what is the
best mechanism
for us to get our stuff installed there
right right
and and the least do-it-yourself kit go
ahead
yeah in a lot of times it's it's these
it's it's a long instruction list of
things that you might want to do
okay and a lot of times things that you
might want to do or
are a lot of things that are technically
orthogonal from each other you know you
might want to set up lsp server
all right okay fine fine i get it so
there's no
okay so for each one i mean what we
should be doing is making
our workflow documentation for each of
these editor environments
explaining step by step how you set it
up well already i'm not sure what you
mean if you mean
from within mathematica no i don't
i don't mean from within language i mean
what
you do you are given an implementation
of sublime somebody says i've got a
version of sublime
i want to edit wl files what do i do
when you say workflow i don't know if
you mean generally or
no no no i mean a specific word i i have
a very good idea of what you mean
stephen
and i can i can do you know what i'm
talking about brenton the the whole
documentation
class of documentation uh items that are
called workflows
do you know what i'm talking about there
you view through mathematica yeah
well they're also on the web they're on
the web
if they're not in pro if they're not
inside of the package that we just
installed here in sublime
it's going to be a lot less no
the point is that there is a workflow
somewhere and if it's in product it will
be on the web so it'll be really easy to
find that there is a workflow that says
i want to work with wolfen language in
sublime what do i do
and then there's a document that says
you know here's
you know here's the recommended you know
10 steps and what you can do as a result
um what i can say is that we want to
install
a new package could you stop sharing for
a second let me show you something and
then i have to go
yep
stephen i i i know exactly what you're
looking for uh
i'm just surprised that brenton doesn't
know this stuff my my my one question is
express is that having the stuff hosted
on the web is
not discoverable as easily from other
text editors as you think it is because
we're obviously not typing this in if
you knew to go to reference.wolfram.com
to begin with
yes this is the search on the web for
how to set up wolfram language with
with sublime that's what has to work all
right
reference reference.wolfen.com is highly
seoed
it's brenton you're acting like if it's
on the web no one will ever find it
that's not true
what i'm trying to do this is a typical
example
configure ruby for external evaluate
that's a typical
type of one of these workflows okay
that's the kind of thing
i'm expecting one would say is configure
sublime
to you know to use orphan language tools
yeah and this
and it can exist sure yeah i'm sorry
yeah and that definitely can and should
exist okay fine
that's what we're talking about all
right i have to go it's
just steven the one question i'm trying
to get in is um i i haven't
worked with anyone in detail on uh on
workflow documentation
is that scott fisher is who is the best
person for that
i don't know but you should not be in
this loop i mean
brenton needs to work with this is not a
place which it needs your specific time
yeah this is this is for me and brenton
um we can talk about this with
scott and other documentation people
okay terrific all right i have